I'm Dan Callahan I'm Cal ahead on
Twitter I work for Mozilla and I'm gonna
be talking about web assembly so I say I
work for Mozilla I think it's important
to note that Mozilla works for the web
and and what I mean by that is that
every major browser except Firefox is
controlled by one of the three largest
for-profit corporations in the world
Mosel is a non-profit and we exist to
strike a balance between public interest
and private interest on the Internet to
really realize the human and the public
good potential of the web and we do that
not just the rabbika see but by building
a web browser by building Firefox in the
open as free software to really put our
principles into practice so so Firefox
it's a great browser but it's also the
only browser that that is at the table
when these large corporations are making
decisions about the future of the web
decisions about DRM decisions about
tracking we're the only party at that
table that doesn't have a profit motive
in how you use the web so if you think
that's important if you think that's
interesting you think the web is a is a
public resource that that needs that
balance between public and private
please check out Firefox we've got a
really exciting release coming out in
November you can preview it today and
developer edition which is what I'm
going to be demoing in without further
ado gonna talk about web assembly want
ask one question who knows what that
logo on the left is just shout it out it
we the Mozilla developer Network we kind
of we pulled a KFC it is now just MDN
the letters don't stand for anything
anymore
but but we run a wiki that is more or
less the canonical reference for
JavaScript and CSS on the web most
people don't know mdn is a wiki if you
if you need documentation if you think
you can explain something better please
feel free to edit it better web Doc's by
us for us was the tagline a long time
ago check it out we're also behind the
rust programming language you wouldn't
you and writing a rust or heard of rust
a couple people all right cool yeah talk
to me afterwards it's I want to know
what you're doing
anyway web assembly
I'm gonna talk to you about web doesn't
believe it my talk is mainly a bunch of
disorganized live demos if you want to
read about web assembly I highly
recommend googling four-lane Clark she's
one of my colleagues in developer
relations at Mozilla Twitter is Lynn
Clark she's written articles a cartoon
intro web assembly which is this really
great illustrated guide to what this is
how it works what it does
cartoon intro shared array buffer what
web assembly means for react she has
these amazing amazing series of articles
and talks that kind of boil this down to
something really pragmatic and relevant
so so if you want reference material
googling Clark after the talk web
assembly is a compiler target for
programs on the web what does that mean
so show hands who here primarily works
in a high-level interpreted language
like JavaScript or Python or Ruby
okay that's almost everyone is anyone
here a C or C++ hacker a couple of
people okay yeah so so compilers I mean
if you're if you're doing front-end bug
gulp and you're probably used to by
these days using a transpiler like babel
to convert your code from from one thing
to another from modern JavaScript to
backwards compatible JavaScript what
assumably does is it gives you a
compiler that can convert from
traditional programming languages like C
and C++ to something that runs on the
web and the best way I can think to
explain this is is by demoing it so if I
come over here I don't know C and I
don't know C++ and I've never been a
low-level developer so I went and I
found this 2005 open source 3d demo and
it's it draws a cube and the cube spins
and it's colorful and apparently this is
what you do in graphics programming 101
but I'm a geology major so I have no
idea what this is I found out it's open
source and if I build it I can say yeah
make native and I get this binary out
that's built for my Mac and when I run
it I get a spinning cube and the cool
thing about languages low-level
languages like C and C++ is that they're
portable so just like the web I the web
doesn't care if you're on Mac or a PC if
you use portable little of languages you
can say actually compile this for window
compiled this for Linux compile this for
Android and you just have to you have to
you have to choose what you're compiling
for but you can target a bunch of
different platforms well what does
somebody lets us do is say compile it
for the web so all I do is I say instead
of outputting this cube binary output
output build slash web assembly dot HTML
and what I get is a dot wasum file which
is a compiled binary program that runs
that same exact code unmodified in my
browser and this doesn't care if I'm on
Firefox or Safari technical preview or
Chrome or anything else it doesn't care
if I'm Mac on Windows it doesn't care if
I'm on Android if I'm them Intel or arm
I can take the same codebase that hasn't
been touched in 12 years and say ok
instead of spitting you out spitting out
a binary for the web or for a Mac or a
PC spit out a binary for the web does
that make sense is that kind of cool ok
I'm gonna I'm gonna limit applause from
here on out because that demo is kind of
awful and you should not have clapped
that much well it's more nursing's
taking something if you have a compiler
you can compile arbitrary things right
so the unity engine can also export to a
web assembly so this is one of the unity
tutorials a little tank demo or I can
drive my tanks around and I can win the
round because web assembly lets me play
this game using 3d using sound at more
or less native speed in my browser
without any plugins on any platform web
assembly goes where the web goes
similarly
and it sticks a little longer to load
but epics Unreal Engine can also export
to web assembly so you can take these
triple-a game engines and anytime you
have a URL you can just send people to
this game send people to this experience
I know that AutoCAD is also being ported
to webassembly all these major
applications that you can just link to
now and they run and this is all being
rendered in real time and going camera
finishes zooming do go look at the fish
pond and this is the full unity our full
Unreal Engine in my browser compilers
can compile arbitrary code the web can
do things like WebGL it has Web Audio we
have all the tools we need we just
didn't have the performance and we
didn't have the compiler now we do
so that's webassembly or at least that's
what was somebody's capable of let's
stop that from playing sound back to the
presentation so why do we need why do we
need something like this on the web why
do we need a new binary format why
couldn't we just compile to JavaScript
so so the big motivators that plugins
were dying so so if you remember back in
the day of having to install flash or
Java or Silverlight or QuickTime or Real
Player or Adobe Acrobat Reader or all
these things that hooked themselves into
your browser to display different types
of web content it was an awful awful
time because every one of those plugins
was native code so they they weren't
protected by your browser security
sandbox you had to compile it just like
that native cube demo you had to compile
your plug-in your java version for linux
and for windows and for mac OS and then
when a platform like android comes out
well maybe flash doesn't work there an
iphone maybe flash doesn't work there
because the plugin hadn't been ported so
we had to get away from this and get to
something that was universal like the
web should be but all we had on the on
the browser side was JavaScript and
JavaScript is hostile to the sort of
optimizations that are necessary if for
instance your adobe and you want to port
over the decades and decades of human
effort that have gone into your PDF
engine
so you want to be able to take that
exact code that you already have and
reuse it on the web you can compile it
to JavaScript but it wouldn't run fast
enough because javascript is an
interpreted language and it doesn't have
good type information I'll talk about
what this means but it's it's really
hard for a computer to optimize
JavaScript ahead of time and this
effectively meant that you couldn't
reuse existing code on the web so we had
to fix that that's why we needed to
build web assembly and we built it with
a couple of design goals in mind one be
as safe as universal as JavaScript to
run as quickly as native code and we're
within about 20% of that that target 3
provide consistent predictable
performance so one of the challenges
with JavaScript especially with a game
engine is that JavaScript
garbage-collected
which means that as your program is
running at some point your program will
stop running and the browser will go and
look through and see how much memory am
I using am I still using that specific
chunk of memory ok I can release that I
need to keep this etc and that's fine
for most applications because you're not
going to notice the framerate of your
spreadsheet slows down we absolutely
will notice if the framerate of your
game slows down or it stutters or it's
inconsistent whereas with the lower
level language like C or C++ you can
control exactly when you release memory
how you handle memory when you request
it etc and we also wanted to have code
reuse between the web and native there's
an enormous enormous universe of
low-level code that is available to
every platform but the web if I'm
building a browser for you know for
mobile for desktop etc I can go and rely
on Lib JPEG or any other portable C
library to do image decoding or stream
processing or whatever else I need but I
couldn't then take that same library
into the web itself
well this simply fixes that questions
before I move on to the next chunk
questions no questions okay so so we got
here through experiment that Mozilla
initiated several years ago called Azam
js4 he said all right well can we make
JavaScript fast enough can we make it so
that the browser can can optimize
JavaScript ahead of time and what we
basically did was write a lot of
JavaScript that did nothing like for
instance we do a bitwise or with zero
for a variable which if you few bitwise
or any value with zero you get that same
value out so it's a no op but we've
inserted these things as kind of coded
messages to the compiler to the runtime
to say this is going to be an integer or
we add zero to it if we want to signal
that this is a floating-point number and
so we had this way to kind of hide type
information inside JavaScript and then
our JavaScript engine could read that
and say okay I'm gonna opt out of normal
JavaScript I'm going to use this
restricted smaller subset I'm gonna
treat this JavaScript like C and it
actually worked it it went really fast
and we actually had several browser
vendors microsoft included that went and
implemented Azam's a s in their browser
and so this is a chess AI that microsoft
built where they used the exact same
code one version as 'm json' version in
normal JavaScript and all they changed
was the the flag that says treat this
like c and and what happens is each of
these a eyes gets a certain amount of
time to plan its next move and because
the Azzam json' doesn't have to worry
about garbage collection it doesn't have
to worry about type checking it has a
lot more budget for actually doing the
computations that matter in this program
and so if i go and look at the cheston
engine output you can see that the azam
james version despite being identical
code by being able to opt out of garbage
collection by being able to opt out of
type checking and kind of escape these
these things that make javascript a very
productive but slower language the azzam
james version was able to to consider
four times as many possibilities it was
able to search three levels deeper in
the possible tree of of game states and
so that wins and so we proved that we
could build something that was just
JavaScript it worked it was backwards
compatible but it was faster and we got
Microsoft on board
and Apple and Google implemented some
some optimizations as well and we
started looking at this and saying okay
but there's something here there's
something that we can do we can make the
web a lot faster and there's value to
that if we all agree what's holding us
up why don't we just go ahead and break
with the past build a new binary format
thus webassembly demos so I don't like
keynote okay so one speaking of browser
support before I go into the demos
Firefox and Chrome whether somebody
works today Safari technical preview and
the next release of Safari web assembly
works there by default the next race of
edge weather simply works there does
anyone know when web assembly first
appeared in a browser on by default
March this year so we went from no
implementations to now by the end of the
year all major browsers are supporting
this brand-new executable format in a
year the web historically has not moved
that quickly and I think it's a really a
real testament to the the potential of
assembly that we were able to make that
happen
an example of some of the great things
obvious and we let you do in terms of
performance see look at a web DSP this
is a demo a suite of demos a group built
where they implemented a bunch of
different video filters so you can
invert the image you can grayscale it
you can do edge detection and they wrote
them in JavaScript and again javascript
is a fast language but it's not as fast
as some of these lower level languages
that give you more manual control and so
you can see that the frame rate here is
just it's not great it's not smooth and
so what they did is they went back they
kept the same API and they said okay
we're gonna we're gonna keep all these
same filters we're gonna re implement
each one in C++ and compile it to web
assembly and then they do feature
detection so in this library loads it
says does the browser support web
assembly if so use this faster version
of the filter if not use the JavaScript
fallback and so if I turn off the
JavaScript version you
see this immediately is just perfectly
smooth you know it runs in much closer
to real time compared to the JavaScript
version so so there are a couple lessons
here one webassembly can make
computationally intensive things go
faster - it lets you take existing code
to the web and these are these are
completely different use cases because
even if there was no speed-up it's still
really valuable to be able to to use a
library without reinventing the wheel
inside the browser or if you're trying
to do computation it's really valuable
to be able to do that quickly and be
able to have control over over
processing and how things work well this
simply gives you both and and like with
this demo as an in developer you may
never have to see what was in will you
mean I have to never have to touch it as
long as the libraries and the frameworks
that you're depending on implement
things so it's it was very possible to
see something like you know react might
implement a virtual Dom kind of
reconciler inside web assembly wrap the
rest of it in reacts JavaScript and
you're none the wiser all of a sudden
just your app runs faster on the web and
that's the future we're trying to get to
where you can build these small reusable
core libraries share them both on the
web and off the web and everyone
benefits but you also you don't have to
become a C hacker - to gain from this as
an end user developer questions before
we move on to binaries yeah
which languages can be compiled to
webassembly so right now webassembly
doesn't support garbage collection or
things like that so you have to if you
want to efficiently compile to web
symbol you have to be using a language
that does manual memory management so
that means C C++ rust has an
experimental target there's been work on
swift and D web assemblies being
implemented natively inside LLVM so any
languages that go through the LVM
compiler toolchain Objective C Swift etc
should eventually be able to target web
assembly yes
sorry can't hear from up here hmm
API limitations I've got a slide on that
we'll get to it in just a second so I
want to step back for a second to talk
about this optimization in the binary
format stuff so what I have here is the
wasm Explorer web assembly Explorer that
we just kind of an online code fiddle
and let's we type in C so let's say int
foo and X return X divided by 4 and
compile it and what you get over here is
a textual representation of the web
assembly program and this is kind of
it's like a you can think of it like a
Java bytecode or LVM bit code it's kind
of it's not quite machine code but it's
close to it and this will work anywhere
you send it to a browser and then the
browser compiles it down to native code
specific to the architecture you're on
so I'm on a Mac so this is x86 assembly
and you will never have to see this when
you're working with all the symbols this
is just kind of a peek under the hood
but we take this and we say ok convert
it to actual machine code and then this
is what runs in the browser the cool
thing about about being able to use a
language like C or C++ is that you have
type information and you have compiler
that has access to that information
ahead of time which means you can make a
lot of optimizations you you cannot as
easily do in JavaScript so in this case
we're dividing X by 4 and so inside the
body of this function we get X we get 4
and we divide one by the other
you'll notice the the type I 32 so
whether simply has 32 and 64 bit in sand
floats and that's it very very primitive
data types but one of the things that we
can do and see is we can say this is an
unsigned integer which means that it's
always going to be positive or 0 and if
you know that instead of dividing by 4
you can shift every bit over by 2
because functionally that if you move
the bit every time you move the bits
over you're cutting the number
half but this doesn't work you're
dealing with negative numbers this is a
lot faster to implement in silicon on
under CPU than a full you know floating
point division and the cool thing about
it is that that when you run JavaScript
your browser is watching every function
you call it's watching every every
instruction that executes and it's
trying to figure out okay am I always
dealing with positive numbers then maybe
I can maybe I can do this sort of
optimization but it takes it a while to
warm up it takes a while to get into
this optimized form and every time you
call the function it has to check that
the inputs are what it expected so maybe
the first 99 numbers were positive
integers but the hundredth is negative
and then it has to throw out that
optimization and start again with
webassembly cuz we have this type
information upfront we can do that
compilation or do that optimization
during compile time and the browser can
start with optimized code as opposed to
to having to figure that out as you go
every time you load the page does that
make sense okay
general general nodding some side to
side but but the big the big deal is
that web assembly lets you provide more
information to improve the performance
of your code once ahead of time seconds
been longer compiling on my machine and
everybody else's browser benefits how do
I actually call this so I'm gonna
download this file open up my console
can anyone tell me how to write an xhr
an ajax request without using jQuery
new okay you actually look confident I'm
gonna use fetch fetches a new API uses
promises it's much easier so I just say
fetch test azzam and it gives me a
promise which eventually turns into a
response so I can say then with the
response response to array buffer so I'm
gonna turn that that wasum file into a
series of like an array of bytes more or
less that gives me a promise I get this
array buffer out then with that array
buffer I'm going to take that and I'm
going to say now webassembly dot
instantiate that array buffer and then
again promise this this is all
asynchronous all in the background it
returns immediately and does the
computation in the background that
eventually turns into a value which is
an object which has two properties
instance in module so let's go ahead and
pop this out as a global variable so
tempo so we have this this object has a
module in an instance when you compile a
web assembly file you get a module in
instance and just just real quick to
show you that what this is let's see
them downloads test up azzam what we're
sending to the browser is this it's a
bunch of gobbledygook that you can't
read because the contrast white high
contrast if I run that through xxd it's
completely binary there's no human
readable text in here at all aside from
at the very beginning this null ASM
which is kind of the magic number so you
look at these first bytes and you're
like oh this is an assembly file you can
see things like foo there's a name of
our function but otherwise this is all
binary this isn't JavaScript it's not an
encoding of JavaScript it's a completely
different format for programs and we
compile it when we do that conversion
from the intermediate bytecode into the
native code we get two things we get the
module which is the compiled version of
the code this is like an exe file on
your desktop and we get an instance
a running copy of that code like
something you'd see in the task manager
and so I can say instance exports foo
and now I have a reference to that that
function we defined over here and so if
I call this with like the number 64 they
get back 16 this is code this is
JavaScript and a JavaScript number being
passed from JavaScript into webassembly
doing a computation and passing a number
back out this is how you can
interoperate between the two now the
only things you can share because
webassembly has a very primitive data
type you can only share integers and
floating point numbers 32 and 64-bit
this is still valuable does javascript
have 64-bit integers does JavaScript
have a new jurors at all no by
definition every number of Java scripts
afloat which only gives you about 53
bits of of integers if you're trying to
do emulation if you're trying to do
certain types of of computations not
having those extra 11 bits is actually a
huge Panda but well this simply gives
that to you if you want to pass more
complex things like I want to pass a
string or an image into web assembly you
can use what's called shared array
buffer so you can basically in
JavaScript set up a really big array
where each item in the array is a byte I
didn't say okay well simply look at this
and the weather simply can change that
array you can write to it can read from
it it can pass a pointer back into the
array to you so you could say okay I've
got this memory call the webassembly
love with somebody goes and gets its
data from there does the computation
puts it back and signals that you should
reread that so you kind of have to you
have to do some work again you probably
won't do this library authors will do
this frameworks we made that make this
easier but right now just passing
numbers works great what happens if I
pass a string
what is hello world divided by 4 0 this
seems surprising but it's really no
different than if I check what the
square root of hello world is
in all these cases javascript has
well-defined conventions and rules for
how you convert from one data type to
another and remember that the
webassembly gets to say what data types
it wants to operate on and so as we're
going from JavaScript planned to web
assembly land we pass through these
conversions and it turns out that
strings we just pass in zero so the web
assume we never see is that string
because it was expecting an end and so
we're gonna give it an end one way or
another questions yeah
so so several questions there and this
your question about security will tie
back into your question about api's and
access you have top file size how that
works so that that demo was 95 bytes so
it's very small that was one of the
chief things that we were concerned
about with with azzam j/s it was we were
adding all this extra information of
javascript and making just he's like
multi megabyte JavaScript packages which
is just awful webassembly is pretty
small it Jesus even smaller was easy
so those gzip larger because they're so
tiny but real-world code goes smaller
that's weird
all right okay so so does everything get
downloaded every single page it works
the same as in JavaScript libraries so
because what this simply has explicit
imports and exports you know what you
need you know what you're getting you
can cache it just like any any other
JavaScript file you can put it on CDN
when you do that web assembly dot
instantiate and you get that module back
out you can shove that in index DB and
pull it out really quickly like we can
pull out unity in a or unreal in like I
think a couple of milliseconds the
compilation takes a little longer at
first but once you do that you only have
to do that once for architecture just
like was JavaScript you have to ship
your own libraries unless you're relying
on a CDN or something like that
you can hook together external libraries
so I could pull in you know live a dot
wasum and use that from my own custom
food wasum so you can kind of you can
think of it as just a more efficient
encoding for a javascript file more or
less the compiler that that's being used
right now is called him scriptum EMCC is
the command line let me make this
inverted and what amis krypton does it
it actually has built into it ports of a
bunch of different libraries so z lahood
PNG STL for doing 3d and graphics and
sound and what it can do is it can you
can use these libraries just like you
wouldn't see your c++ and then scriptum
has like a shim that understands how to
take an OpenGL drawing call and convert
it to a WebGL drawing call and so you
can kind of has there's some things
built in otherwise you can compile your
own libraries the hard thing is how do
you interact with the outside world what
api's are available and if I knew my
slides well note which I may not talk
about that open standard we talked about
that this so so right now in your
browser there are kind of two worlds
there's the JavaScript engine v8
SpiderMonkey etc and that has a
JavaScript interpreter it has a guard
Derr it has a compiler because we have
to take that JavaScript in and try to
get it into faster native code once we
observe it so you've got a profiler with
all this machinery to make jobs are
Brunton but for it to do anything it
needs to be able to do i/o it needs to
be able to to show results on the screen
it needs to be able to make sounds make
requests through the web etcetera store
data and that's what what the web
platform brings so you have things like
WebGL Web Audio indexdb web worker
service workers these are the api's that
you use to access the outside world - do
I owe what do you think about
webassembly your JavaScript VM is trying
to get somewhere close to there already
it's trying to look at the JavaScript
and say how close can I get to native
code and still be correct
well web system he does is basically say
let you shortcut that and say well hey
I've already got the native code or
something really close to it just use
that and so we can host this right
inside the same compiler runtime
platform that's already in your browser
so whether somebody kind of exists as a
peer to JavaScript inside all these are
major browser engines and more or less
is kind of it just skips that first
phase and cuts in a little bit later in
the process
this means that web assembly is running
inside the same exact sandbox and has
the same restrictions as any other
JavaScript so if you want to do
something on the screen you have to use
WebGL if you want to make a raw socket
connection well you can't you can do
WebSockets you're subject to the same
origin policy you're subject to all of
the same restrictions that you have in
JavaScript it's just now it's a
different binary that's that's kicking
all this off which means that there
should be no security problem in web
assembly that is not also present in the
JavaScript engines more or less the
other cool thing is that we're calling
it web assembly but who here's used
nodejs look at most people right is node
useful yeah it's it's a reasonable
reasonable platform to work with well
what no does is it takes the same thing
but it just it gets rid of the web
platform bits it just gives you the
JavaScript runtime and that's still
useful and what assembly does the same
thing and note 8 supports web assembly
and sure you don't have access to like
WebGL
but you have access to other things and
you can expose things differently
depending on what context the runtimes
end so so well weather is simply
starting in browsers there's nothing
that keeps it there this is truly a
general-purpose executable format that
just happens to be born out of the web
does that answer your question okay you
good another question
so you have access to all of those but
how was that actually exposed in your
seat coats and see isn't quite like
JavaScript literally just random right
so how is that exposed so in the same
way that I cannot do this reliably as a
live demo because live coding is
stressful but I will we show you the
compiled bit so just like in C for
instance if I have a an external library
an external function I want to call I
can say all right X turn int bar takes
an int and then down here I could say
all right first pass let's say X equals
bar of X so if we're gonna we're gonna
call this external function modify the
value and then do our divided by four
and when I compile that we did this
import stands out that says all right
import from the environment something
called bar and so you can do that by
like supposing and then when we call
this a no I'm not gonna try to it live
but we call that webassembly dot
instantiate you provide a separate
dictionary that says imports bar and
then you can provide a function here
that yeah X and then return X times 10
and then what that would do is is make
that JavaScript function available
inside the C just like you would use to
access any other external C thing this
means that people still need to build
good reference libraries to expose the
web platform to see that's an active
project but you can it's possible to do
right now and that's what I'm scriptum
does with its built-in support for
things like STL file system access if
you just using the normal C API is try
to open and write to a file
the unscripted compiler will map that
into opening and storing data inside
index dB so so there you can build that
that kind of translation into the
compiler yeah
so what are the consequences of having
raw memory access having pointers and
things like that and see and then bring
that to the web and web assembly so so
with web assembly you can request memory
in 64 K chunks and you can allocate from
there or allocate that and deal with it
however you want but you are still
limited to explicitly the memory you
allocate so you've got this kind of
virtual memory manager this is alright
this is the memory you have access to
you anything you try to access outside
of that is just not going to we're not
going to allow that to happen at the
compiler level when we do the
translation from the gasm bit code into
into the native code that makes sense
yeah yeah
I am I'm coming from the JavaScript
world I'm not particularly familiar with
how shared objects and linking like that
works and how it works in here I know it
is possible we can talk more afterwards
I can get your info and I can put you in
touch with an engineer that actually
does hack at that level
it is an independent specification just
happens that the first implementation is
inside LLVM because we had we've done
that work for as MJS it is finalized the
one day shift in March and we are to the
best of our ability not going to
introduce any backwards and
compatibility changes
I think available changes the the binary
format there will be new features that
were quite a future direction just like
in Javas we have to say you know do I
support fetch so I can use that instead
of xhr but but there's a way to do that
okay so low level stuff so what is this
again compiler tart with the web
low-level binary format open standard
with cross browser support direct
successor of as MJS and is a
general-purpose virtual architecture why
is this interesting so this doesn't
replace JavaScript it expands what the
web can do you can do things on the web
that are faster you do things on the web
that perform more consistently you can
do things on the web that reuse existing
code this enables new hybrid designs
where you may have a core of your
application you may have the
computationally intensive parts
implemented in any language like C or
C++ like we saw that that stream
processing edge detection filter but the
API you exposed to your users is
JavaScript so there none the wiser they
don't have to learn this but they get
better performance it means that for
compilers the web is just another
platform it's here today it works today
I talked about as MJS being this like
kind of Cluj of a hack to see can we
make something faster and still make a
JavaScript yes well that means that for
backwards compatibility you can compile
to wasm and just save the Azzam j/s
artifact as well and serve that to
browsers that don't accept web assembly
so there's there's a good back compat
story coming in the future better
tooling multi-threading sem d we want to
add garbage collection of assembly
that's probably a two year project but
but really trying to make this platform
a capable platform that can really
natively interact with with the web it's
javascript is a great language but it
should not be the only language FAQ is
this JavaScript dead or dying it's alive
its monopoly on the client-side is dead
that's the big takeaway that the the
notion that you have to know JavaScript
to work on the web is no longer true as
of March this year however you can't
just take you can't just come in as a
C++ developer and say now I can work on
the web and expect to have an experience
that feels like the web so both of these
communities have a lot to learn from
each other about how to build things
that that best leverage the strengths of
each platform to company each other
you've got a high level textual language
in JavaScript you've got a low level
binary language format and webassembly
makes new things possible older browsers
again you can compile to as MJS to wasm
will just save the as MJS output the
compilers right now in scriptum is the
experimental compiler we've been using
for as MJS for the last six seven years
upstream LLVM is coming hopefully soon
but for now you'll be using him
scripting and then Benari and is the
program that does the translation from
azzam jsn to Azzam can I compile
JavaScript web assembly some people look
at this like oh if I'm using typescript
or JavaScript can I just compile my code
do i zoom and make you go faster don't
do that
anyone want to guess that why you
shouldn't do that
you already have a really good Java
Script I'm in your browser it knows all
the dirty tricks and all the awful
secrets to make things go fast for
JavaScript and web assembly doesn't know
that much about datatypes so if you want
to run javascript in your browser using
your own runtime well you have to come
with your own way to represent objects
and strings and things like that in
memory again your browser already has
one and it's great
what about type errors are kind of
demoed this so there are well defined
rules so it's no different from calling
the square root of hello world at that
boundary and there is overhead so
webassembly we're working to lower it as
much as possible but crossing that
boundary from JavaScript into web
assembly and back there is overhead
where we have to do type checking we
have to do type coercion which means
both assembly is typically better if you
can get the data into it once and
operate there versus calling two of
assembly a whole lot at a high rate I
have a couple closing demos
this is the the real fun part let's see
so let's start with pipe ijs so I said
you had to bring your own runtime and
that means that it's it's not as
efficient to take a high-level language
and put it on the web I have a a
colleague that looked at this looked at
this so Python there's a Python runtime
called pi pi and pi PI is written in
Python so you compile Python to see pi
PI to see and then you put that into GCC
and that compiles to C into a native
code and you put Python into that native
code and then you get it jetted back
into the native code again so this is
kind of the pi PI interpreter or runtime
script him does something similar it's a
compiler so you take C you put C into
and scriptum it spits out JavaScript the
Java circles into your browser your
browser turns that into native code so
that works so if you switch these
together he rose well we can take pi pi
convert that into c put that into him
stripped him to convert the C into
JavaScript put that into your browser
which converts it to native code now if
you Python into that native code in your
browser we can have that spit out as 'm
j/s which your browser will then get
back into native code and now you have
python the web so so he built this as a
proof of concept and this was before
whether simply this is just using using
Azzam j/s but it works and the problem
is like okay you have to bring your
whole Python runtime with you but that
that means you've got like an eight
megabyte javascript file not awful you
don't want to do this on every web page
but but it's possible and that file has
all the information about like how to
represent a Python object in memory and
so now I can say from test import PI
snip license a bench mark built into pi
PI or Python things a pice domain
and this is running natively my browser
and I'm getting about 150 280 270
thousand of these these benchmark
computations per second if I come over
to my actual my actual computer and run
this natively
I get like three times four times slower
performance than running in the browser
and so so this is this is smoke and
mirrors that the difference is this is
PI Pi which is an alternative runtime
for Python this is C Python which is the
reference runtime so if I did this in pi
PI from test import PI stone by stone
main then my native computer will go a
lot faster however most people using
Python are using this version and
they're happy with it and so this is a
proof that you can get something running
faster than than the native common
version of Python on your desktop inside
your browser and the only overhead is
you have to ship a whole Python
interpreter with it because whether
somebody doesn't know how to do garbage
collection it doesn't know how to how to
represent other types of data that's
cool
let's compile another thing also this is
the tabby cat extension every time you
open a new tab it gives you a new cat
it's wonderful all right so this this
will take a minute to load but somebody
compiled DOSBox to web assembly and dos
boxes and windows is a kind of Windows
emulator and so this is an immediate
version of Windows 31 for workgroups
running in DOS box compiled web assembly
my browser we rendering to an html5
canvas which is then being painted let's
expand this into a web view our context
or WebGL context and and that dial-up
modem sound you heard this is actually
fully multi-user so if anybody else
loaded this you could actually see their
camera flying around as well using
WebSockets but I can come up here and I
can you know it'll take forever but I
can open up Netscape
in my 3d environment in my browser
emulating a Windows computer on Intel
and it works actually I wonder does this
actually I haven't tested example.com do
we actually have network access oh hey
we do so connects hack
so so this worked and this is this is
thanks to webassembly that we can get
this and it's it actually performs
reasonably and so you can use this for
awful things and you can use this for
amazing things but you can use this
today and it does things that the web
has never been able to do before
the kicker plugins things like that you
had Google's Native Client which was
dare attempt to replace JavaScript you
still had to compile for every target
architecture or every target operating
system and so even if you had something
like this it you know it wouldn't work
when all of a sudden phones come out and
now we're all carrying around arm
computers in our pocket instead of Intel
computers in our pocket but whether
somebody's processor agnostic so I can
load this on my phone and I swear to god
and I will happily demo it to you it
will work on my phone as well emulating
an Intel processor running Windows on an
arm piece of silicon in my pocket and
because you've got an accelerometer you
can look around the environment and you
put on the Google cardboard this is web
assembly everything has changed and it
changed in March and we haven't realized
it yet and so what I want to do with
this talk is not so much to tell you how
to make something practical with this
but to tell you that this is possible
and go out and learn and play with it
and look at Lyn Clark's talks if you
want to actually learn something about
this with like helpful illustrations I'm
just trying to get you excited about but
exciting cool
[Applause]
Oh somebody else is here so there's
there's another camera also kudos to
whoever on the connect tech team made a
version I made the website made the
markup such that it works in Netscape
Navigator 3 released it loads something
that's that's incredible I've got seven
minutes I'm gonna leave you with one
last thing who's used SAS front-end
developers okay most people have touched
this somebody implemented SAS and C++
SAS was originally written in Ruby and
people like me and that's great but it's
pain in the butt to call Ruby from other
languages because Ruby has its own
runtime its own idea of things and
that's one of the benefits of the
low-level language is you can call from
one to the other really easily so
somebody employed SAS and C and C++ and
now you can call it from go and Java and
JavaScript and Lua in all these
languages there's a version of this for
nodejs
node SAS this again speaks to the
compilation problem because what node
SAS does it supports this matrix of
operating systems architectures and node
versions because they're shipping native
code they have to compile for all of
these different targets ahead of time
and so each of these is a couple of
megabytes and there are dozens of them
for every release so hundreds of
megabytes of compiled bindings and data
every time note SAS makes a new release
somebody that is not me somebody with
more C++ compiler experience please for
the love of God compile node SAS two
webassembly set the node min Verta eight
and just ship one little web assembly
binary cuz it'll work everywhere in all
of these environments that's that's what
I think is really exciting this ability
to take these libraries and stop caring
about the processor but still get most
of the same performance the world is
rife with these opportunities live
archive supports all of these different
formats it's portable C works everywhere
it's used in the BS DS it's used in a
lot of popular applications if I want to
do something in node I go
the archiver packaged downloaded almost
90,000 times today
it handles zip and tar and it had to
reinvent that wheel well the assembly
means that if you're using node if
you're using the browser you can stop
reinventing wheels and you can make
things faster and you can do stupid
things like run DOSBox
and that's capable in a little 3d
environment that has Jolt Cola and
Fritos so thank you so much if you have
questions I'm here all day today I
unfortunately have to leave tomorrow
morning
but please find me there's stickers on
the back table
I have plushies you ask questions other
people ask questions I can't I can't
throw it all the way back there so I'm
just gonna start tossing these out and
before you go I have the Firefox you
have to win the Firefox who can name to
see you so a lot of front-end people who
can name either of the two women that
are most instrumental in the development
of the CSS grid specification
Rachel Andrews the other is Jin Simmons
congratulations I'm not gonna toss this
you can come up and get it all right
three more thank you so much
I'm Cal ahead on Twitter don't forget
Ling Clark on Twitter if you want to
learn more about this and have a great
conference
[Applause]